so here we are
Avengers Assemble who are you people
again hi I'm Troy Baker and I play Bruce
Bennett hi I'm Jeff shine and I played
Captain America
I'm Travis Willingham and I play Thor hi
I'm Laura Bailey and I'm playing Black
Widow hi I'm Nolan North
I play Tony Stark there's certain
characters I don't think you ever have
to be talked into yeah you know so we'd
like to have you played Tony Stark Iron
Man yeah yes you know everybody always
portrays him as this super confident
character I think it's a mask for him I
think he's one of the most vulnerable
guys I think Bruce is just such a cool
character a lot of people are really
quick to bring out the big green but I
think that that Bruce is a super complex
character he's fun and I've never played
him before
what is very relatable about Natasha is
she's extremely capable but she's at the
core she's human she's surrounded by all
of this larger-than-life stuff and she
has to step up to it
I feel like Thor got really interesting
in the last like 10 or 15 years from for
me I like where he's kind of landed in
the public eye you know one of the
things I think is cool about cap is I
never feel like he he necessarily wants
to be a leader he accepts that he is
feel like sometimes the best leaders are
the ones who don't necessarily want to
be but they're right for the job having
an original story to tell as well what
they've done at Crystal Dynamics is
great so I think everybody would be
pretty stoked the Avengers are at their
best when they are all together but the
chemistry is no do not shake thanks
everybody for joining us can't wait for
you to be able to play the game but
right now you don't have to wait for
some exclusive content
you
do the Avengers pose a danger to society
that was the question Bruce that was the
question did you even check the signs
did you it was a heist Bruce no we were
outsmarted the Terrigen reactor was
unstable and you knew that you knew that
and you still paraded it before the
entire world what we just give up we
didn't give up Tony we failed at least I
can admit that we failed him we failed
him
you